siempre sigo más de todos los deportes
pero un día tuve la oportunidad de hacer
un trekking en nepal y cuando empecé a
caminar por todo esos caminos
maravillosos encontrarme rodeada de una
inmensa montaña majestuosa
un silencio y una gran paz interior y
desconectada completamente de afuera y
completamente conectada conmigo misma de
ese aguado que está pasando que es
alguna sensación completamente nueva de
esto que tengo el trekking regrese a
venezuela y empecé a tener la necesidad
de la pasión de conocer más la montaña
empecé por lo más básico que era la vida
se cocía medidas a nuestro bello páramo
y era como una etapa enamoramiento no
desea más y más esa parte de pasión y
condición que sentía con ellas
decidiendo por un grupo amigos
d
bolivia estuve en argentina el aconcagua
que es la montaña más alta de américa y
ya también aquí y mancharon estaba en
áfrica
desde esos viajes tendríamos aún más la
necesidad de conocer la montaña y
conocer otros lugares diferentes
este grupo amigos éramos compañeros y yo
forman una expedición que se llama
venezuela venezuela 8000 nos plantemos
es una montaña que de todas hay 14
montañas 8.000 metros a los cuales la
mayoría están en la corrida
decidí no hacer una que se manchó sólo
en tibetano significa damas burguesas y
esta montaña tiene ocho mil doscientos
metros siendo la sexta montaña más alta
del mundo
lo interesante es la montañas del tíbet
ya han hecho de estar allí está bien con
la cultura
esa cultura tibetana budista realmente
para mí es una primera experiencia
maravillosa empezamos a hacer todo lo
que es la preparación para la expedición
suena fácil pero no es un equipo de
comida logística porque realmente no
está un lugar completamente algo
empezamos en un campamento primero el
campamento base donde es como la casita
de estar a 5500 metros más o menos
imagínense un poco más lo que implica
volver
parte de la montaña es la aclimatación
es la parte más importante la
alimentación se basa en hacer campamento
altura
porque estamos en capa método base
empezamos a hacer el primer campamento
de tratamiento de 1 punto de mis
compañeros se sintió más le dio un edema
pulmonar ahí empezó el primer impacto la
expedición tuvimos que bajar
inmediatamente lo primero que se tiene
que hacer
pero cuando llegamos durante recorrió la
bajada veía expediciones congelado
lo que quería hablar con mi amigo
con otro compañero se fue y quedé que
dejó uno y yo el día siguiente me
levanté me senté frente adama turquesa
tuve una conversación con ella esta
convención que necesita fue
de decir de que yo tenía años
preparándome para esto año meses
preparándome mental físicamente
y sé que va a haber muchos obstáculos en
esto pero que me permitiera en su vida
que me permitieran conquistarla
esto es parte también del montañismo
cuando estamos estos lugares
no le pide permiso a las montañas porque
somos seres somos seres completamente
invasivos y contaminantes de perth en
esa conversación con ella que me permita
cumplir conquistarla empezamos a subir
mi compañero y yo todos
y totalmente tres del día siguiente se
hace el ataque la mujer porque tengo una
idea más o menos el campamento 23 hasta
7.300 metros y el campamento y la cumbre
está a 8 mil 200 metros es un desnivel
de prácticamente 900 metros es ascenso
empezamos el ascenso de la madrugada muy
temprano y el otro compañero le queda
conmigo se sintió mal y tuvo que bajar
de ahí me quedé con el club y ser para
que una persona q lo lleva para que la
llevó el ascenso y de paso y yo me llevé
una bombona oxígeno porque yo quería que
las condiciones fueran las óptimas para
ser un mes
este hombre
y decido bajar y hoy entré en pánico
obviamente porque tenía que llevar la
bombo conocí a steria profundo y empecé
a decir no me siento preparada me siento
confiada en hacer esto a mi reloj un
bono chino lo puse en mi moral y sigue
subiendo fue una jornada casi de 9 horas
esta jornada ha terminado muy bien de
algo que es alta montaña cada 100 metros
se recoge ninguna obra
cuando fue todo ese trayecto lo que hice
fue siempre concentrarme en cada paso en
cada respiración no venga de arriba
simplemente cada paso cada respiración y
pensar y me enfocaba en lo que yo quería
por supuesto estaba este nueva de
cansancio deshidratada en alta montaña
sufren de anorexia deshidratación porque
la logística de prepara comida es de
retirada es menos un proceso a lápiz
puesto sordos llegó está arriba llegó a
campamento llegó a
hombre de oro y cuando uno llegue me
sentí y ya no me siento como estar en
ese lugar sentí verdú y lo primero que
fue desarrollar y las gracias a dios y
las personas que hicieron realidad todo
este proyecto y ayudarme 360 grados
estaban rodeadas prácticamente de labor
diaria la cordillera del himalaya y en
una de esas vistas me encuentro con él
eres el deber es siempre lo he visto en
fotos y siempre le he visto desde abajo
y cuando lo veo al frente realmente me
puse a llorar de la emoción en emoción
que sentí desde allá arriba
después estamos gratuita
y disfrutar de ese día hermoso hermoso
me sentía más en contacto con jobs esa
es la altura que vuelan los aviones
prácticamente pero después detuvo allí
en vez de 6 me cambié mi bombero
enciendo y empecé a bajar se dice que
cuando uno hace cumbre hace cumbre no
cuando llega a la cima sino que el
evento vuelve hasta el campamento base
porque se dice esto porque nuevamente en
el descenso siempre ocurre los
accidentes porque porque acaba si estás
deshidratados estás cansado y ya bajan
la guardia ya no cubren prácticamente en
la mayoría de las de las vueltas de los
accidentes que una vez se llaman lo que
llaman muerte de planta no me armé de
valor también y un conocido me puse la
otra en mi morral y empecé a bajar hubo
varios eventos realmente complicados en
el descenso pero bueno siempre siempre
enfocan qué es lo que yo quería enfocada
en mi mente porque mi cuerpo ya no me
daba más estaba realmente cansado
y si más
y cuando me coherente de otros es
conmigo misma y vencer los miedos bien
sin los temores en el descenso empecé a
bajar empecé a bajar poco a poco con
mucho cuidado cada paso para no tener
ningún tipo de accidente o evento ya que
eso significa realmente la muerte en esa
altura
después una de las bordadas
prácticamente de 14 horas de regreso al
campamento base llegó ya de noche pero
ese día descanso este que pensaba él
también hecho el día siguiente
nuevamente me siento frente a la dama
turquesa y le doy las gracias
gracias de haber permitido conquistar la
gracia del me permitido estar allá
arriba en su cima y humildemente
humildemente agradecido de haber hecho
un sueño en realidad y esos sueños
realidad no sólo meter alguna meta que
yo me había fijado
en la primera mujer venezolana
una montaña de más de 8000 metros y
poner la bandera de mi país venezuela
penando en su mente no de gran
satisfacción y obviamente cuando regrese
a venezuela de mucho mérito y siempre
los grandes después te cuento que estoy
echando kim que fue un momento muy
importante vivió tengo otro también casi
o lo que es un try en el salvaje
una caminata elegante fui
yo simplemente no sé
empezamos el rappel
cuando terminado por esos lugares yo
sentí una energía también muy especial
muy diferente a lo que fue el de la alta
montaña por el verde esas maravillas que
tenemos este país ver esos esas aguas
con los rojos con el camino de rodeada
todo es lo que es el atlántico y
realmente yo estaba en belleza
embelesada de estar ese lugar cuando
empecé a hacer el rapel el primer papel
es complicado porque es a él simplemente
no tienes ningún punto contacto pues
nuevamente nuevamente entré en pánico
y nuevamente me conoces y me enfoqué a
lo que yo vi nacer a ti
al tomar y siempre siempre se le pide
permiso a estos altos lugares sagrados
para ellos tanto para los animales como
para los pemones en ese lugar empecé a
bajar la prima parte está complicada una
mala logística en la cuerda y no mente
se baja en un día y tiempo de dormir
literalmente sin darle apariencia
obviamente complicado espacio de habla
no así pero cuando estábamos ahí lo que
lo que sentía en la nochecita en la
noche era el arrullo de la caída del
agua el santo
me desconecté de cualquier miedo que
tenía y el sábado y ese sonido realmente
me marcó
realmente súper bien bajamos y
nuevamente cuando estoy abajo la veo en
esa inmensidad qué significa ese lugar
nuevamente en las gracias
que concluyó de todo esto lo que
concluyó todo esto que se dice que
a lo que el montañismo como tal es un
deporte para hombres deporte rubro pero
no es así
cuando uno hace montañas
realmente tienes que sentirte apasionado
porque haces y qué mejor que más que las
mujeres
apasionada y entregadas a donde hacemos
somos valientes y prolongó y nos
proponemos simplemente lo logramos
para mí en mi experiencia durante tantos
años es cuando las cosas se hacen con la
conexión desde el corazón hasta la mente
enfocado en lo que uno quiere dejar
muchas veces los sesgos que uno tiene
alrededor simplemente por ser la primera
mujer o hacerlo primero no es la
situación persona alguno siente haber
logrado un sueño y que sea la realidad
y es una amiguita esa herramienta de
lucha
sobrepasar cualquier tipo de obstáculos
de ciencia siempre seré agradecida de
todo lo que me pase mi vida dando cosas
buenas y no tan buenas porque me ha
hecho una mejor persona
y orgullosa de ser venezuela
debidamente si yo nunca había hablado
así
y yo lo puede hacer cualquiera de
nosotros podemos hacer y es el mío
para ustedes propongas en las cosas
desde el corazón
desde la convicción de entrenamiento y
lo van a lograr créame